I couldn't stay here just watching not
taking action and responsibility I just
follow my father instinct of course many
times was afraid of course the best type
is above my head and bumps and attacking
in hours that maybe I thought in my head
there is love for my son and if there is
a God away five months
they're just coming from the front and
they wonders you see his hands near this
figure posing with rebel fighters this
is the incredible story of one father's
desperate search of his audacious
journeys into a war zone to track down
his jihadi son and if the risks he
continues to take to help other families
it's so sad that that that parents like
me and so many thousands of fans
worldwide are standing alone that
nobody's helping them is disgusting
really it's selfish believe me it's here
in the belgian city of antwerp where our
story begins
a tale of radicalization and of a father
sense of helplessness as he watched his
son's descent into extremism we see that
something is going wrong and of course
we know why because he was a member he
became a member they selected the
recruiting for Shayla Phobos I'm a
radical salafists extremist organization
Islam organization and who to change the
attitude of our Western childs who
change or some who indoctrinate them who
brainwash or some would totally take our
Western child from his own parents
this is Jojo and bomb tech an
accomplished breakdancer he appeared in
a number of Belgian music videos but
soon after he converted to Islam
the teenager began to show signs of
radicalization he became increasingly
distant from his family in their
desperation they reached out to the
authorities for help but his father
Dmitri says their concerns were ignored
it was a nightmare really very painful
for us to see that our own son always we
teach him what we educated him that it's
totally gone like the wind like he goes
to gone in the air this was very painful
for us as parents and of course we asked
help everywhere by the police by the
authorities by youth organizations
please help us because we see that
something is going wrong we see that it
is not good for his future and they were
just watching the answer was we are
living in democracy you have freedom of
speech or freedom of relay of religion
you have freedom of organization so it
was very sad for us very sad very
painful
like so many European cities Antwerp is
grappling with an extremism problem
dozens of young local men have traveled
to Syria to fight alongside rebel groups
to join bond Tec took that same journey
he left his family devastated with was a
table for us believe me I couldn't sleep
anymore we were in a tragedy I don't
have words for it believe me what
happens
it's that did this international
mechanism the change of indoctrinating
change totally is live is ideology
everything in all kind of ways and
step-by-step preparing to send him to
conflict area like Syria and today it's
still going on not only by physical
organ organizations but also by social
media by internet Dmitry says he tried
repeatedly but failed to get any help
from the Belgian police or government in
tracking down his son eventually he took
the extraordinary decision to go after
his son himself chronicling his journey
in a video diary this follow you I
follow a father instinct I follow my
heart not without my son you know I
couldn't stay here just watching not
taking action and responsibility I just
follow my father hot father instinct you
know
this is Dmitry on the syria-turkey
border at the start of what would be an
almost year-long hunt for his son it was
a danger mission and believe me I
respond in life I meet many fighting
groups in Japan are out of it so many
fighting groups are also the creation of
Isis that time the name of the fighting
was mission should a council of much
idea of course many times was afraid
indeed all around with the sights and
sounds of war me live at the local one
who the Unruh comes from the wreck
this is how I'm a dance team
the follicles
I'm Bob fuller
beating
he toured local hospitals looking for
his son all he found there were many
graphic examples of the human cost of
this Civil War here he's making his way
through the rubble stone streets of
Aleppo under the cover of darkness but
the danger is ever-present of course
there were snipers above my head and
bumps and attacking and when we were
driving with the car maybe the the the
racket fall down on the car and I was
that maybe but as a former Belgian
soldier Dmitri was more comfortable than
most around this war zone by friending
many rebels fighting the Assad regime
even posing with their weapons for
Syria's victory for senior
but here with this year it was an
amazing mission why because in Syria
have seen the really meaning of the true
meaning of Islam the good Islam and the
Baths Islam so I got a lot of support of
Syrian people because for them it was
amazing that the father from the West
who is not a Muslim risk his own life to
come to a war zone without support
without solidarity without respect of
his own selfish government to find his
missing son a son who became one of them
who became a Mujahideen for them so it
was really amazing for them so they
helped me they support me so I respect
him I understand them the Syrian people
but some rebel groups were more
suspicious of this Western father at one
point he was taken prisoner suspected of
spying they put the cap above my head
and handcuffed me and beating me from
here and from here it took two weeks
before I could breathe normally that
time I was thinking is it it all worst
to risk my life to such my missing song
but I thought in my head there is love
for my son and if there is a God that
will release me and I will find my son
and they release me in fact he says the
vast majority of Syrians couldn't do
enough to help him track down his son
you sure you mature your son but just he
say doesn't team but we
we must meet him for ask about your son
yeah okay spec out after three trips to
Syria Dmitri was eventually able to
rescue his son and bring him home the
first time I met my son physically it
was very emotional and I really hold him
like a small baby we were crying like
duman's did he want to come back of
course absolutely absolutely absolutely
because he know that he had been used by
the wrong friends by the wrong people
he know that you have been let us call
it naive but he know that have been
really used by the wrong friends and by
the wrong people and in Syria his eyes
go open that they use him
chiju and bond take told his father when
he became disillusioned and desperate to
leave Syria he was locked up by rebel
groups as punishment at one point held
in a Cell alongside British hostage John
Cantlie and us journalist James Foley
who was later martyred by Islamic state
they spent a lot of time my son learned
a lot from John Cantlie I'm from James
knowledge about making his own computer
to build how to build his own computer
really yeah they were like split
spiritual fathers for my sons because
you know they're older than my son and
they learned him a lot about journalism
and all this kind of things now back
home news of Dimitri's rescue mission
has spread quickly among other families
worldwide Rosanna Rodriguez teenage son
run off to Syria last year
Brian de Mulder also converted to Islam
in Antwerp before becoming radicalized
his mother fell apart attempting suicide
before Dimitri offered to help really
converse of course Dimitri talks to
people parents have lost their kids but
the authorities don't want to help they
don't care and there's no support I was
praying to God that Dimitri would see my
son and bring him back but it didn't
work out that way
although Dimitri has made contact with
those Anna's son he's refusing to come
home
after avais the store's owner okay
I met Dimitri through our shared
experience of sons running off to Syria
and that's how he started talking on the
phone and we spoke about our children
the pain that we had the loss that we
felt for our children and I thank God
that mitri got his son back
unfortunately my son still hasn't come
back but Dimitri knows those he brings
back could face prosecution like his son
now at the center of a huge terrorism
trial in Belgium accused with more than
40 others of being part of a band terror
group his father continues to support
him attending court every day and he's
highly critical of Western governments
for criminalizing rather than helping
those who have been radicalized with
this wrong attitude and this
stigmatization they're creating more
frustration against the rest they're
creating more violence against the rest
is totally wrong we thought Leo the
former soldier claims dozens of other
families have sought his help including
some from Britain I thought I will never
return to Syria but you know when
parents when mothers are calling me and
crying on the phone and telling them
that nobody is helping them and they're
standing completely alone and that
governments are just watching and doing
nothing and when they ask to meet me I'm
not going to say no because I was in the
same tragedy in the same nightmare as
them so of course then we come to meet
me and when a mother is crying in my
present in my face and begging me please
help me you think I'm gonna say no
demetria's journey to syria eight times
now the risks are obvious but the father
who rescued his own son from the
clutches of the jihadists will soon be
back there again determined to help
other families